alors anne hidalgo la candidat ps qui
veut se lancer dans la course à l'élysée
coûte que coûte malgré les sondages
toujours inquiétant la primaire
populaire qui aura bien lieu pour tenter
de réunir la gauche fin janvier sans les
candidats yannick jadot les candidats
jean luc mélenchon également fabien
roussel bref la gauche chacun pour soi
point d'interrogation on attend vos
réactions sur le conte télégramme et
c'est l'objet de notre décryptage
[Musique]
est avec nous pour en parler sur ce
plateau patrick le hyaric
éditorialiste à l'humanité bonsoir
patrick le hyaric merci d'être avec nous
nous accompagne également stéphane rozès
politologue président de cap stéphane
rozès qui enseigne également à hec à
sciences po vous allez également
stéphane rozès conseillers de zs ancien
candidat socialiste à la présidentielle
ségolène royal en 2007 et françois
hollande en 2012 vous connaissez donc
extrêmement bien ce sujet de de la
gauche parmi d'autres sujets que vous
maîtrisez merci d'être avec nous donc
l'un des chiens on l'a vu réunis dans la
rue aujourd'hui contre le protocole
sanitaire de jean michel blanquer r pas
vraiment unir dans les urnes vont nous
faire réagir messieurs je voudrais vous
montrez ce sondage le dernier en date
est la barrière voici ce que ça donne
jean luc mélenchon à 25% yannick jadot
6,5 je vous laisse découvrir le reste
des stores anne hidalgo qui n'est même
pas assez pour 135 nathalie arthaud en
queue de peloton 0 5l rotois thalassa
fait 23% des intentions de vote pas
moins de huit candidats en dessous des
10% stéphane rozès votre réaction votre
analyse
ces chiffres mais une gauche à 20 % il
ya dix ans un tiers des français se
retrouvait donc la gauche et les
difficultés de la gauche que vous avez
nice et ne vient à ce long mois de sa
vie sion celle inverse c'est parce que
la gauche c'est dans la dernière période
éloigné de ses fondamentaux la nation la
question sociale la république qu'elle
s'est peu à peu et demi n'était est
divisée quand la gauche est indexé sur
le sujet pays et sur ses fondamentaux
quelles que soient les volontés des uns
et des autres des dynamiques majoritaire
uniterre se met en place et bien là
celle inverse donc nous sommes
certainement à la fin d'un cycle à avec
une tendance de chacune des sensibilités
de gauche a essayé de retrouver des
fondamentaux soient écologistes soient
des coûts fabien ussel
communiste ceux qui sont les plus en
difficulté
c'est plutôt la famille socialiste qui a
oscillé dans la dernière période
entre
néolibéralisme et
communautarisme
vous êtes d'accord avec cette analyse un
petit peu dissonante de stéphane rozès
et français nous irons là ils se
planquent tout simplement parce que
c'est chacun pour soi ouais et chacun
vit sa vie c'était une mauvaise m'ont
dit non c'est parce que tout simplement
la gauche s'éloigner de ses fondamentaux
vous partagez vous ce déclic oui je suis
assez proche de ce que dit stéphane
rozès une expérience du dernier
quinquennat
laisse des traces extrêmement rude et le
fait que de ce dernier quinquennat vous
parlez de celui de france fort celui de
françois hollande donc le parce que
n'oublions pas que le parti socialiste a
eu la totalité des leviers pendant un
temps il a lui même la présidence du
sénat la majorité des départements la
majorité des régions le le gouvernement
de majorité à l'assemblée nationale donc
ils avaient les moyens de créer les
conditions pour affronter la
mondialisation capitaliste il ne l'a pas
fait il a accompagné et le fait que sort
de ce quinquennat l'ancien secrétaire
général adjoint de l'elysée ministre des
finances eh bien ça brouille est encore
plus les cartes et le nom le mot gauche
aujourd'hui pour un certain nombre de
gens ne veut pas dire ce que nous
souhaiterions c'est à dire le combat
pour la justice l'égalité
l'environnement et la démocratie
stéphane rozès c'est à dire que la
gauche a finalement trahi son électorat
tout d'abord comme le dit patrick le
hyaric avec françois hollande et avec
emmanuel macron parce que c'est vrai
qu'on se souvient tout de même qu'il
était à gauche et dans un gouvernement
socialiste
je fais remonter le divorce un peu en
amont au fond comme la gauche et au
départ le parti socialiste semble
renoncer aux questions sociales pour
aller vers les questions sociétales
substitut la république d
d'assembler des minorités c'est la note
de la fondation
néolibérale terra nova
prétendants ou font faire converger des
minorités de nature différente et puis
je rajouterais doux l'intérieur
d'ailleurs pour moi de la candidature de
fabien roussel c'est que pour fois la
gauche
semble-t-elle disparaître parce que la
situation est tellement grave
pour les français que le sud vienne
n'est plus seulement essentiellement
économiques et sociales mais cds de la
france elle même et de son modèle or ce
bienvenue la gauche dans la dernière
période
elle ne parle plus de la france elle
parle des questions purement économique
et social mais qui sont inclus avait
dans notre histoire
dans l'agression nationale et je ne vois
pas que la gauche puisse revenir sans
poser la question de la souveraineté
et de la reprise de la france u2 sur la
maîtrise de son destin et lads dont la
gauche est bien être par l'économique
social écologie c'est pas ça soit pas
important mais c'est enclavé dans la
question première qui est pour les
français la question nationale la
question de la souveraineté
la question de la maîtrise de notre
destin patrick le hyaric c'est un gros
mot pour la gauche la souveraineté c'est
l'apanage de de la droite qui s'en est
emparé et c'est votre année du tout la
notion de souveraineté populaire est une
notion de gauche est à dire la
possibilité pour les citoyens de décider
réellement quand on leur a dit vous avez
pu voter non contre le projet de
constitution européenne mais quand même
on l'appliquera c'est le contraire du
respect de la souveraineté populaire
dont ça a porté un coup extrêmement dur
à la démocratie elle même et à la
croyance dans la souveraineté mais ça
c'était pas spécialement la gauche qui a
trahi effectivement dans l'es7 allusion
au référendum de 2005 il ya eu un
référendum de 2005 sarkozy est arrivé au
pouvoir après on a effectivement pas
forcément cette île à faire c'est une
majorité des parlementaires socialistes
et d'ailleurs on se souvient qu'il ya eu
une fameuse une d'un grand magazine que
je ne citerai pas ici où il y avait
ensemble président sarkozy et le leader
de l'opposition entre guillemets de
l'époque françois hollande qui a appelé
à la même chose 1 c'est à dire oui et
donc à partir de ce moment là la
question de la souveraineté populaire
c'est-à-dire une partie de la question
que soulève s'était fait une grossesse
elle elle est évidemment elles à
discréditer ce qu'on appelle la gauche
il faut ajouter à cela c'est que il y a
eu un accompagnement quand même de la
mondialisation capitaliste
dès les années 80 trois cantons n'a
de créer les conditions pour favoriser
les bourses de la liberté de circulation
des capitaux
ce qu'on a appelé la compétitivité c'est
à dire la mise en concurrence des
travailleurs entre eux qui permet les
délocalisations à partir de ce moment là
on a fait très mal à l'électorat de la
gauche c'est à dire au sens large à la
classe ouvrière c'est à dire aux classes
travailleuses et à l'intérieur de
ceux-ci aujourd'hui on est dans une
autre phase i à une mutation on n'est
plus tout à fait dans la classe ouvrière
regroupées dans deux grandes entités et
c'est dans le livre par exemple de
jérôme fourquet renvoi que
les travailleurs dans la logistique ce
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui une partie des
premières lignes des premiers de corvée
de vienne ont une place extrêmement
importante seulement ceux là sont isolés
ont des difficultés à se syndiquer en
difficulté à trouver
du temps d'abord pour militer dans des
associations ou est dans un parti
politique de gauche pourquoi un candidat
comme arnaud montebourg quand on écoute
vos deux discours n'imprime pas
davantage stéphane rozès 10.5
aujourd'hui dans ce dernier sondage
d'arnaud montebourg qui va probablement
se retirer
on fond vous avez raison de poser la
question ainsi arnaud montebourg avec
fabien roussel à gauche étaient ceux qui
portaient la pression de la souveraineté
[Musique]
et puis ring seymour apporter des crises
ion la france au plan identitaire et
culturelle marine le pen à sa façon pose
c'est l'addition de la souveraineté mais
qu'est ce qui s'est passé avec arnaud
montebourg eux c'est que il a abordé la
question de la souveraineté sous l'ongle
du patriotisme économique sous l'angle
de
l'économie or selon moi
subjectivement riz
objectivement la le malheur français la
crise française
ne vient n'a pas comme origine un
dessaisissement d'abord de sa
souveraineté économique et social
il a d'abord une cause politique ça a
été dit la nation française pour
préserver ces rapports sociaux a besoin
de se projeter dans l'espace le temps
une vision et le sommet de l'état
demande à la nation de faire le verse
d'intérioriser des disciplines économie
de l'union européenne mais ce processus
a comme fondement selon moi une raison
une cause non pas économique et social
mais d'abord politique donc le projet
d'arnaud et d'efforts internes 101 sur
le fond sauf qu'ils étaient abordés
toujours par l'économie et ce n'est
qu'après qu'il posait les questions
politiques de la france de la république
il aurait fallu selon - flers lembeye on
va regarder cette réaction télégramme de
pascal la gauche s'est trahi et
discréditer en faisant croire à ses
électeurs qu'elle avait des valeurs de
gauche là ils sont
patrick le hyaric c'est on en revient à
cette forme de trahison c'est ce que
ressentent beaucoup d'électeurs de
gauche aujourd'hui belle trahison c'est
à dire on n'a pas créé le rapport de
forces pour affronter la mondialisation
capitaliste est là étaient accompagnés
et le parti socialiste et notamment qui
étaient intégrés dans le parti
socialiste européen qui était déjà avant
cela bien plus à droite que le parti
socialiste français parce qu'ils avaient
un parti communiste relativement fort et
bien s'est aligné sur ses dogmes en
quelque sorte est devenu avec le choix
y'avait telle la marge de manoeuvre pour
faire autrement oui parce que on peut on
peut en appeler au peuple on peut même à
un commissaire européen dans le
socialiste dans le collège des
commissaires il peut s'opposer un
certain nombre de choses au parlement
européen au lieu de faire des alliances
entre le groupe de droite et le groupe
social-démocrate on pouvait créer une
autre alliance écologiste gauche
unitaire et socialisme ce qui a été fait
parfois mais qui a montré qu'on pouvait
modifier un certain nombre de choses et
surtout s'appuyer sur les volontés
populaires c'est-à-dire sur les
mouvements sociaux que voulez vous quand
on a emmené les canons à eau contre les
infirmières ça nous dit quelque chose
aujourd'hui c'est quand même un ministre
socialiste qui a emmené les canons à eau
contre des infirmières qui manie fait
qu'ils manifestaient il ya de cela
très longtemps parce qu'il fallait
rentrer dans ses dogmes
européiste en quelque sorte c'est à dire
une europe
très libéral donc c'est toutes ces
questions là et dans le cas d'un
affaiblissement
de la force du parti communiste est un
parti socialiste qui se déportait de la
social démocratie authentique vers un
social-libéralisme parce que
le mot gauche à appliquer à tout le
monde aujourd'hui à toutes les forces
politiques induit un certain nombre de
confusion je crois c'est fanny l'algo
donc on n'en parlait a confirmé qu'à
lire et coûte que coûte au bout de cette
aventure ça fait une participante
d'ailleurs en moins à la primaire
populaire ça veut dire que c'est fini
pour christiane taubira où elle peut
finalement transformé en une candidature
de gauche supplémentaire
il ya la question des parrainages
christiane taubira devrait emporter la
première populaire
bizarrement sur le fond arnaud
montebourg qui a peu à voir avec eux les
positions un peu
impressionniste ou poétiques de
christiane taubira
devrait se rallier mais de toute façon
il faut les les parrainages donc je
crois que beaucoup se disent la
présidentielle s'est perdu et à dalou
qui sur toutes ces questions a
énormément varié finalement sous la
pression du parti
socialiste ils se disent bon c'est foutu
la présidentielle mais autant
conserver ce que nous sommes pour la
près
donc
la position et effectivement
pour d'algos de courir sous ses propres
couleurs au risque d'un
cataclysmique et faisant que le ps se
réduisent à un des fiefs locaux autour
de quelques métropoles et région
ségolène royal a d'ailleurs réagi
aujourd'hui elle dit la gauche en
substance est la seule responsable de
cette situation les diviser chaotique et
elle n'a pas su organiser de primaires
n'a pas su travailler avec ses
partenaires cette question patrick
numérique de primaire ça aurait pu quand
même sauvé un petit peu un petit peu les
choses au moins pour apporter un
discours lisible des propositions d'ici
pour
l'idée
l'idée sympathique que l'ifo faut pas la
rejeter d'emblée ceci dit une primaire
pour quoi faire et sur quels objectifs
parce que le problème il est là le
problème c'est que quand madame hidalgo
elle dit qu'elle veut revenir à la
social démocratie et la semaine suivante
elle va à tulle et se déplace au marché
de thunes avec françois hollande elle ne
donne pas le signal qui revient à la
social-démocratie ce que j'appelle la
social démocratie authentique parce que
françois hollande n'a pas incarné la
social démocratie il a incarné un
social-libéralisme très libérale
d'ailleurs quelques fois il n'y avait
pas toujours du social est
donc une des questions qui est posée
aujourd'hui
pour nous tous pour les médias pour les
responsables publics etc c'est de
réfléchir c'est à dire que on a des
portes et où le débat à droite depuis
des mois et des mois rendez vous compte
que la primaire de droite à 2 a fait
l'objet de quatre débats télévisés dont
un débat sur la télévision publique
pendant ce temps là la gauche a été
étouffée est aujourd'hui la seule
campagne à propos de la gauche c'est de
dire il faut qu'ils aillent à une
primaire populaire mais ceci ne fait pas
dans tout état de cause ne ferait pas
gagné strictement une voix la question
qui est posée c'est de laisser les
forces politiques de gauche exposé
d'ailleurs moi j'aurais été content il a
été très heureux si tous les candidats
de gauche et même toutes les forces
politiques de gauche puissent bénéficier
aussi de dessin primaire des débats
politiques entre eux devant les citoyens
de telle sorte que les citoyens se
fassent leurs opinions et d'ailleurs sur
les plateaux de télévision bail peut se
faire on voit les dissonances on voit
les divergences on voit aussi les points
d'accord
mené campagne uniquement aujourd'hui sur
cette question la primaire populaire
empêche parce que ça crée de l'illusion
empêche l'électorat de gauche de se
mobiliser et créer des conditions pour
augmenter l'abstention du côté gauche
voire pour empêcher la droite et
l'extrême droite à refaire voter macron
même s'ils ne sont pas d'accord avec
monsieur macron merci beaucoup à tous
les deux patrick à lui hérité fans rozès
d'avoir été avec nous pour nous apporter
votre analyse sur cette gauche qui est
décidément bien en en difficulté à trois
mois de l'élection présidentielle et
c'est la fin de cette émission